i think russ
is another person who everything he does
is very organic as far as the people he
works with like i never see russ force
any features like he's like yo if i [ __ ]
with him i [ __ ] with him
like he's a he was he was a fan of you
to work with yes
like and i was offended him too so like
i love his music
so when he hit me he was in l.a he's
like i'm in la like you know i got some
studio sessions and he don't even do
studio sessions like
out at the studio he recorded at home at
home yeah so he's like you know i'm out
here i don't really do this [ __ ] but i
got a session if you got time i'd like
for you to pull up i got some beats for
you
so he had some beats originally and to
play me as i was listening to them we
heard the the best on earth
and we were like man let's get on this
right now we just both felt it
cut it right away he did a hook i did
the other half
he did a verse i did the other half of
the verse so it was organic
like real that's fire